well members of the migrant caravan are
not american they're not even in the
united states yet according to the left
that makes no difference to the left
there are two groups of people in the
world
current american citizens and american
citizens who simply haven't shown up yet
if you don't want them here immediately
then you are
a monster watch the president united
states has decided
that a couple thousand scared sick you
know people fleeing violence are a
bigger threat to the united states
than isis i spent two days with a
caravan and i didn't see criminals or
rapists or
terrorists donald trump feeds off of
this kind of ugliness
and cruelty and his supporters back him
on it because they didn't get the wall
but now they might be able to stop a an
imaginary caravan
people have gotten so much dumber in the
last two years it's unbelievable
and it shouldn't surprise us that in the
face of programming like that
a dozen honduran migrants have sued the
administration for supposedly
violating their constitutional rights
even though once again they have not yet
reached the border yet
and they are of course not american
citizens mike donovan is ceo of nexus
services which is financing that lawsuit
he joins us tonight mike thanks a lot
for coming on
and for example thanks for having me of
course a sincere question and i i really
am glad that you're here
because it's hard to see what the
standing is here these are people who
are not american citizens they're not on
american soil
and some of them have declared intent to
violate american law
how are their constitutional rights the
constitution of a country
they're not part of how are those rights
being violated exactly
well so of the of the name plaintiffs in
this lawsuit
each of them and each of the individuals
in the in the purported class
are individuals who want to seek asylum
and do so legally so i think that's an
important part
of this conversation but tucker it's
it's a good question
the asylum so we have an immigration law
it's a series of immigration laws and
one of those elements is asylum and and
those
laws uh are specific to the individuals
in this caravan who are coming to claim
asylum
that pro that in alone it may not be
enough but the
president of the united states has taken
to making this
caravan a symbol of an invasion of our
country
and he has taken a great deal of time to
defame the individuals who are
traveling fleeing bloodshed in their
home countries
trying to find a place where they can
live and and and
support their families okay i guess what
does that have to and i understand you
don't like that and you're on their side
you don't like trump
fine but what does that how does that
mean that they have a constitutional
right that is being violated what is
that right where in the constitution
does it reside
as just a normal american i'm confused
can you help me
yeah absolutely it's a right to due
process these individuals are coming to
the country
um they have in one way or another
stated their intent to come to the
country
and the chief executive of this country
has taken aim and attacked them so
what i'm saying is that their standing
is very simple they're asylum seekers
they want clarification i think that we
should respect these uh
migrants maybe we should wait
there's a legal question so i get it we
should respect them you you're on the
side of the migrants that's
that's that's your right i just want to
know
where my responsibility begins as as an
american citizen
you're saying they have a constitutional
right to due process but they're not
americans
and they're not on u.s soil they're
hundreds of miles from the united states
they're not here so in what sense are
they covered by our due process protect
like this is insane and you know what's
insane i just want you to admit that
it's
no it's no it's not insane tucker they
are
claiming rights under the asylum
provisions
of our statutes that affords them due
process rights under that law we have
due process under the law this is a law
that is specifically directed to them so
of course they have due process right
now
let me just correct you as a non-lawyer
they do not possess those rights if
they're in another
country and not u.s citizens so if they
possess those rights
then i don't know the entire country of
nigeria or any pick a country that's
poor the united states can say we want
to come there president says you can't
come
and all of a sudden 800 million people
sue you for violating their
constitutional rights in the country
they've never been to
without with all due respect tucker you
know that that's not exactly that's not
what we're talking about here we're
talking about individual
migrants who are coming together who are
on their way to the border to exercise
their rights under
u.s law nobody i'm process right now but
it's not it's not difficult
because it's a few it is what's the
principle in what sense is it different
what's the principle
if you're a foreigner residing in a
foreign country
okay well i don't know if they're in
routers the entire nation of
if the if the entire nation of nigeria
were in route to the united states
perhaps it would be apples to apples but
that's what you said it's not correct
these are
individuals coming to this country to
seek asylum okay
first of all you don't know that we
don't know what their intent is they're
sure
actually you don't they're hundreds of
miles away and asylum claims
have to be made on u.s soil either in an
embassy a consulate or at a border
okay that's the loss because someone who
purportedly defends the law you know
that i know
so you can't actually claim that you're
covered by the us constitution again if
you're not on u.s soil and you're not a
u.s citizen
because if you could unfortunately no
argument but tucker it's not an argument
the courts don't
the courts don't agree with you there's
a court case in the d.c
circuit that is in the matter of ari
r.l johnson where judge bosberg said
that the administration can't use
deterrence to curb asylum seekers who
are coming to this country
i'm afraid that this is an area of law
that's already been litigated
i'm not concerned but you're in you are
incorrect
you are no you're factually incorrect no
the united states the united states
supreme court has never said
that due process protection applies to
non-citizens on foreign soil that has
never happened
that the the district of columbia
federal courts have and that's where
this shows
so are you one day we'll get to the
supreme court i think this is important
but
here's what's important hold on here's
what's important is that the rest of us
know what the president is
and so is by this standard anyone in any
country who says he's on his way to the
united states and is walking in our
direction
can sue the united states for saying we
don't want you
you really want to set that president or
you
do i want to set the precedent tucker if
the president of the united states
engages in abusive violent rhetoric
toward a group of people
this president is behaving badly and you
know you don't like the president you
should condemn it too don't
it's not a matter now you're moralized
like every one of these people
i don't
do i think it's okay i want to talk
about adult things like what does the
constitution
guarantee foreigners is it okay that
he's mean
okay thank you